avoir à sa disposition toutes sortes
d'outils pour la conception et la
réalisation d'objets une opportunité
possible pour les étudiants de l'estaca
grâce aux fab lab ce concept né aux
états unis est un laboratoire de
fabrication numérique intégré au sein de
l'école d'ingénieurs basée à montigny le
bretonneux le lieu est en libre accès
sous la supervision d'un fable manager
ils viennent pour des pour des projets
personnels ou pour des projets
associatifs ou pour des projets liés à
la formation sachant que nous on a des
rares chizé évidemment donc on dit les
la règle c'est que les projets
associatifs sont prioritaires et puis
après les projets formation et
personnels fraiseuse numériques
imprimantes 3d machine qui permet de
graver des circuits imprimés
le fab lab a été cofinancé par la région
ile-de-france et saint quentin en
yvelines depuis son ouverture il ya un
peu plus d'un an il a permis la
réalisation de plusieurs projets comme
un bateau adapté aux personnes
handicapées ou encore la fabrication
d'une fusée expérimentale
parmi les avantages apportés par ce
laboratoire un gain de temps pour lé
prototypage
si on passe par les moyens
conventionnels de production il faut
passer par des sous traitants donc
envahi la pièce au sous traitant le
sous-traitant va évaluer si c'est
difficile ou pas de les produire
ensuite ils valent à produire nous l'a
renvoyé donc s'il ya un petit défaut est
qu'il faut qu'on aille modifie il faut
qu'on repasse par ce process à chaque
fois
votre projet pour l'année prochaine
c'est d'essayer d'organiser
régulièrement le jeudi après-midi quand
ils n'ont pas cours pour les étudiants
qui le souhaitent des petites formations
une formation à l'usinage formation a
l'impression 3d formation sur les
lézardes we know enfin l'équipe de
développement électronique
cet équipement du futur un vrai plus
pour les étudiants ingénieurs de
l'estaca qui pourront encore plus
imaginer inventer les mobilité de demain